Wall Street had a big day on news of a
possible trade agreement between the US
and China the Dow gained 298 today the
S&P 500 was up 20 the Nasdaq finished
ahead 40 President Trump is celebrating
this development but some experts are
saying China may be pulling a fast one
on the US and there is already a
significant amount of hedging from both
sides tonight
correspondent Kristen Fisher reports
from the White House to see before
presiding over the swearing-in ceremony
of the new CIA director Gina Haspel
president Trump unloaded on Twitter
about his administration's approach to
resolving a trade war with China noting
that China has agreed to buy massive
amounts of additional farm and
agricultural products and that barriers
and tariffs will come down after months
of threatening to impose stiff tariffs
on Chinese steel and aluminum the
Treasury Secretary made this bold
declaration on Fox News Sunday we're
putting the trade we're on on hold so
right now we are we have agreed to put
the tariffs on hold while we try to
execute the framework secretary minuchin
says that framework includes China's
agreement to substantially reduce the
trade deficit by increasing their
purchases of goods but when asked
exactly by how much the secretary
wouldn't say there was a reason why we
didn't put a specific number and I would
also say this is a specific number again
whatever we agree to these are not
government to government purchases we
have very specific targets industry by
industry these now
the Trump administration describes last
week's talks with the Chinese and the
framework it produced has substantial
progress and the markets responded
accordingly his fears of a global trade
war between the world's two biggest
economies subsided but today there are
bipartisan fears that this potential
deal is letting the Chinese off the hook
on one of its biggest transgressions
Democratic Senator Chuck Schumer urged
the Trump administration to not sell out
for a temporary purchase of goods
without addressing the real issue the
theft of American intellectual property
while Republican Senator Marco Rubio
said any deal that doesn't stop China
from cyber theft and forcing US
companies to transfer technology to them
is a huge loss so it's unclear if that
issue the theft of American intellectual
property is still on the negotiating
table as for what's next the Commerce
Secretary Wilbur Ross is heading to
China next week to try to turn this
initial framework into an actual signed
agreement Brett Kristen Fisher live at
the White House Kristen thank you